So, in the previous example we
went from kilometers to miles.
And it wasn't too difficult since we
knew the relationship between the two.
Sometimes they'll be intermediate steps.
So let's say you had a conversion chart
with a whole bunch of unit conversions.
For example, here we have relationships
between miles and kilometers, and yards,
and feet, and meters,
centimeters, millimeters.
And then, what the heck?
I started talking about volume and gave
some conversion factors between gallons,
cups, and liters.
Now, let's say you want to convert
a distance that you knew in centimeters
to a distance in feet.
Just a few things you could do.
One option is, you could start with
centimeters, convert to meters,
then convert from meters to yards,
and then go from yards to feet.
Or maybe you want to go from
centimeters to meters and
then from meters to kilometers.
Then maybe from kilometers to miles,
miles to yards, and yards to feet.
In general, there's a lot of ways you
can perform your unit conversions.
In this case I'd prefer option one
because it involves fewer steps, but
option two isn't wrong.
Let's practice this with a problem.
Let's say you're having a party again
and you want to serve 26 guests.
And you think that each of them
are going to drink 5 cups of juice,
but the juice you're
buying sold by the liter.
How many liters of juice should you buy?
Enter your answer in this box.